there are more than 300 million people
in America and each one of us consumes
even as children we use resources by age
two and a half one toddler will have
already consumed 420 pints of milk each
pipe having traveled 100 miles to get to
us during that time that same child will
have used 3700 diapers which in turn
needs 1898 pints of crude oil four and a
half trees and 750 pounds of plastics to
manufacture that's just milk in diapers
for one little baby so just imagine the
resources the rest of our life requires
what would it look like laid out in
front of us
everything we eat everything would drink
all the water we flushed down the drain
all the clothing we wear all the fuel we
use and all the things we depend upon
the average Americans lifetime
consumption physically set up in one
place revealed one extraordinary
television event the human footprint
hosted by Elizabeth Vargas premieres
Sunday April 13th at 9:00 on NatGeo